today is September 7 2016 so it's time
for me to shoot another monthly update
video for the month of September in
which I'll talk about what went on
during august and what we've got coming
up in this this month of September
what's what's left of it unfortunately
there's quite a bit left as usual I like
to begin by highlighting three big
things that I want to particularly bring
to your attention so one of these is a
talk that i'll be giving later this
month locally at the Shorewood public
library on the ethics of anger if you're
in the area the Milwaukee area of the
fox cities or Chicago area I think you
probably want to come to this because
this is one of my main areas of research
and it's going to be a great talk the
next big thing big thing number two is
that right now we're engaged in a lot of
preparation for international stoic week
which is coming up in October so it's
not a September thing but a lot of the
prep work is happening in September so
I'm going to be contacting a lot of
organizations and institutions since I'm
editors stoicism today and seeing who's
doing stoic week events we're going to
put all that together for stoicism today
for stoic week so that people worldwide
can find out what's going on and if
you're interested in having me come in
and give a talk about anything stoic
related i'm certainly up for that during
stoic week of 2016 which will be in
mid-october the third thing third big
thing that I want to talk about is it's
the time of year when students start to
realize what the class is that they're
taking are like and whether they're
going to need some assistance one of the
big things that we do here at reason I
owe is provide tutorial sessions and so
if you want to do better than you want
to book the best is our motto and I've
been tutoring people in philosophy
religious studies and a variety of other
subjects as well for over 20
years so I'm going to be probably
producing a video about that and talking
about that and some other venues if
you're interested in that email me at
Greg at reason I owe the address is
right there and I can hook you up with
it with a session August was a fairly
busy month we had several events all of
them either local or online the first
one we started out the month of August
with one of the lectures in our
quarterly lecture series on philosophers
the midst of history and that one was on
Descartes early modernity and the Wars
of Religion very well attended some
great discussion and questions you can
see the video for it linked below we
also had our would be our eighth lecture
in the monthly lecture series that we've
been doing with the Brookfield library
on speculative fiction and philosophical
themes this time we concentrated on
Ursula kayla green and her Hainish cycle
so we talked about a number of her
novels really wonderful session again
you can see the link to the video for
that below and we had our monthly public
free Q&A on Hagel a little bit later in
the month we do this using google
hangouts will keep using it until google
changes their hangout structure so those
were the events for the month i also did
a quite a bit of coaching and counseling
and tutorial sessions working with with
learners who wanted to set up their own
curriculum for their own studies we're
getting ready like i mentioned for a big
push from traditional students in high
school college university who are
struggling with their classes and need
tutorials i also started something new
and you can see once again a video about
it linked to below i started offering
some sessions for learners with who are
doing homeschooling with a platform
called out school and so we're seeing
how that's going to work we're
sort of experimenting with it been
offering these introduction to Plato
courses and putting some other courses
up there and you know we'll see if it if
it turns out to be something that's
quite viable will continue with it if
not we may pull back from it video work
I finally managed to get my quota of six
half-hour Hagel videos done getting the
last one done on the very last day of
the month very happy about that because
it you know my patreon supporters are
supporting me to get this work done now
they support me / video so if i don't
get videos done they their contributions
don't come in but it's also important
that i get these done not just to
satisfy the people who want them but so
that i can stay on track so that someday
I can take another work other than
Hegel's phenomenology you can see the
some of it back there on the board right
now because I haven't erased it yet but
eventually you know we're going to get
through the phenomenology and then start
looking at other works as well I also
released some Aristotle videos and we're
going to continue to release those from
the Nicomachean ethics there were the
event videos and then of course there's
that out school video where I'm
explaining why I'm getting involved with
out school I've been working on
presentations quite a bit presentations
that I'm planning on giving this fall
many of them focused on stoicism there's
the big presentation at stoic on of
course in October which is going to be a
workshop on stoicism and managing anger
that i'll be giving i'm also doing a
workshop here at marquette for the
graduate students specifically on the
faculty of pro I raices in epictetus
that's going to be some close reading
stuff so I've been putting quite a bit
of time and work into those I my third
piece in the series on epictetus and
resources for dealing with anger one's
own anger and other people's anger in
stoicism today it's one of the benefits
of being the editors I get to every once
in a while slip in one of my own pieces
so that series is now complete and i
will probably after stoic on and after
stoic week take it back up and talk
about some seneca and some other
theorists who discuss anger as well my
epic titas class the online class that
I've been teaching with with reason I
owe finished up and it was it was quite
good we had a lot of excellent
discussions over the course of that six
week class and all i'll be offering it
again next year so those were interested
in that can find out about that i also
did some blogging perhaps not as much as
i would like but i was able to get some
writing done in a rex st and know NTK
with my main blog the one i started six
or seven years ago and in half hour
Hagel so that's what went on during
August we've got a lot coming up in the
month of September there's three events
two of them are local and one is online
so on September eighth which is tomorrow
night brookfield library 7 p.m. i'll be
doing that that sci-fi fantasy
philosophical themes series this time we
are talking about michael moorcock and
his notion of the multiverse and the
eternal champion but will really be
focusing on Jerry Cornelius and the
cornelius chronicles very fun stuff a
little bit of a departure from some of
the other stuff that we've been doing on
the 14th at five p.m. central time I'll
be doing my half hour Hagel Q&A hangout
526 I'll answer any sort of hegel
questions you've got anything about
German idealism that you want to bring
up that I'm actually competent to talk
about and then on the 19th we have that
big lecture at the Shorewood library the
ethics of anger where i will be talking
in fairly general terms about what some
of the great thinkers over
the course of history they had to say
about this emotion and how we ought to
sort it out for ourselves and I'll be
answering questions and and addressing
whatever sort of comments or discussion
people want to bring up this is an area
that I've been researching intensively
now for over ten years and so it should
be quite an interesting talk so those
are the events we've got coming up I've
already got some coaching and counseling
and tutoring appointments on the books
for for this month already done a few
this this week as well and we're also
like I said bit earlier gearing up for
stoic week so stoic week is an
international set of events its
worldwide it got started by the stoicism
today project team of which I'm a recent
recently joined member I came on as a
member and as the new editor of Stoicism
today back in March of this year you
know great welcome by everybody on the
team there's some you know great
scholars and psychotherapist who work
together and the whole idea is to
promote modern stoicism not all of us
are necessarily a hundred percent stoics
I myself and sort of a eclectic blend of
you know stoic and Aristotelian and some
stuff from existentialism but I'm very
happy to be a part of this and what
we're doing is trying to get there's a
lot of events going on worldwide and we
want it to be publicized so that anybody
can go to the site and find out if
there's an event near them and you know
where they might go if there's online
events to find out what's what's going
on so there's going to be a lot of cool
stuff coming up on the back end here I
am contacting literally hundreds of
organizations institutions asking them
you got you got something going on for
stoic week and as a side note if it's if
it's local I'm willing to come in and
give a talk as the
editor stoicism today and somebody who
does research on stoicism particularly
on epictetus i'm very happy to come
during stoic week which will run from
the 17th to the 23rd of october that's a
monday through a sunday if somebody
wants me to come in and it's not local
and they're willing to you know pay for
my travel and book me and all that then
I'm perfectly happy to do that as well
but i'm primarily looking for local
events during stoic week so there's all
of that going on and i'm doing you know
engaged with the team and doing a lot of
planning there's a lot of work a lot of
moving pieces to this but it's really
cool to see what's going on so getting
pretty excited about that i think you
can you can tell what else video work
i'm going to get my six half hour Hagel
videos done for the month and i'm going
to try to get them done earlier than
later so i'm hoping to start shooting
later on this week i'll be releasing
more of the aristotle core concept
videos over the course of this month and
i've also got a few personal videos that
I've been meaning to shoot for a while i
know one you know that i'm not going to
tell you what it is right now i'll leave
you in suspense because you'll see it
coming out probably next week or so i
need to do some more of those dr. Sadler
responds you know where I address common
issues or questions that are coming up
because I can save myself a little bit
of time with with comments and then I'll
do I promise to do a video discussing
philosophical counseling last month
didn't get to it going to try to get to
it this month sep tember is also going
to be a month where we have a lot of
projects building this business reason i
0 which is you know my main work that's
my institution and it consists of myself
and and my wife so it's literally a
mom-and-pop business we do a lot of
teamwork with this sort of thing and so
we're going to be expanding some of the
activities that were involved in we're
going to be sending out a lot
out of inquiries and we may in fact work
on the website during September whether
that may get put off until October well
we'll see there's always some things
that need to be done it's sort of like
owning a house you can always find some
more work to do owning businesses like
that as well so we're going to be
promoting the philosophical counseling
we're going to be promoting the tutorial
sessions we're going to be sending out
queries about speaking inquiries all
these sorts of things and I'm really
quite excited about that by the way I
should mention once again if you're
running into you know snags in some of
your classes or you want to develop a
better understanding of some of the
material that you're studying you know I
provide a lot of free resources online
with my videos but I also provide
one-on-one tutorial sessions so if you
really want to improve your
understanding you can you can book me
just you can go onto the website or you
can find me by emailing me at Greg at
reason I oh and we'll talk about that
here that it's really starting to come
down outside so I'm going to try to get
this done quickly the other things that
that we've got going on I've already
started getting booked for talks in 2017
very gratified to see that so if you're
interested in in me coming to speak at
your organization or your institution
get in touch with me again Greg at
reason I oh and we'll we'll get talking
about that if you if you're you know in
a university and you want me to come in
I can at least point you towards the
right person to talk to to make the
invitation and we'll go from there so
that is what we've got coming up this
month of September looks pretty busy I
hope all of you have a great month ahead
and I'll see you in the ether or a
face-to-face